what's the name of the last person i
kissed
that's a secret i can't tell you
i'm gabby and i'm rachel and we're gonna
see who knows each other better and i
think it's going to be me i'm just like
bad
you're like overall
yeah i want to go first okay okay what
is my ideal date
i feel like something adventurous in the
beginning because you're like an
adrenaline junkie and like maybe
something romantic
exactly perfect next one okay my turn
get to the deep dark slices of the fish
bowl
what's my coffee order
americano what happens
oh my gosh
what's my biggest pet peeve what is it
just when people drive really slow
i'm such a slow driver
sorry
no you're not remember that time we were
driving together you drove us off the
road
in the jeep yeah i am just a poor driver
actually not just slow
what's my most embarrassing moment
just living life
you have to wait and see
her most embarrassing moment
tune in what's my astrological sign your
capricorn yeah and your pisces yes
easy what's my favorite outdoor activity
going on
drinking on patios and going to hot tub
yeah so it's nature that's as close to
camping as we'll get yeah i like to like
dip a toe in nature yeah get back get in
the hot tub get in the pool maybe yeah
ocean maybe depends
what's my best quality um
you're so charismatic that people are
like naturally drawn to you it feels
like you
but and i think you can be put in any
scenario and make the best out of it
like you're always the first to like
lean in
do whatever and like always do your best
never half ass i love that um oh what
are my red flags slash x oh my gosh
okay and everything literally i think
they have to be really good at
communicating they have to have a sense
of humor yeah be able to like
keep up with like your sense of humor
like i feel like you can't have someone
that's super sensitive someone can like
roll with the punches yeah but
sensitivity ick
let's see
oh this one is our favorite question
what are we so what's my favorite drink
um
a champagne a champagne yeah or a shot
of tequila we know a lot about that
i love you i love you
um what did i love most about filming
this season
i feel like this season was so amazing
because we kind of took it all back into
our own hands yeah and i feel like you
really got to show who you are because i
mean we went to some like amazing places
so of course that was like awesome but i
think really being able to be empowered
as women is like
kind of the best part of it yeah
i feel like i have so many friends that
i've known for so long that i don't even
know like on the level i know
yes same everything we've been through
together it's like impossible not to
form a bond yeah and you're such an
amazing person that it's easy to be
friends with you
i love you
the bachelorette is back like you've
never seen it before tune in monday at 8
7 central on abc and stream on hulu